[Musique]
allez on parle culture avant
d'accueillir mes prochains invités
la culture c'est pour tout le monde
cette semaine à saint quentin en
yvelines bon sens mélanie potier alors
pour le coup de coeur culture vous
parlez du baby âge qui se déroule depuis
le 6 avril et médiathèques labadie pour
les tout petits c'est ça alors l'instant
des tout petits ne cesse de grandir
grégory là aujourd'hui sept ans mais
comme toujours le mois d'avril va
tourner autour du livre de la petite
enfance des comptines et la responsable
de ce festival nous rappelle son but
on trouve très peu de spectacle sur la
petite enfance
certains parents imaginent que les
enfants mâles livre une savent pas
parler les livres n'est pas important
pour eux alors qu'on se rend compte à
chaque fois que ça éveille tout un tas
de choses alors babillage mélanie se
déroule jusqu'au 20 avril et c'est dans
toutes les médiathèques de
l'agglomération
oui et cette année le thème c'est le
corps et c'est le mouvement alors il ya
de nombreux rendez-vous des comptes et
des comptines bien sûr mais aussi des
ateliers où les parents peuvent à condat
signer un moyen pour communiquer autres
mois de son enfant et enrichir aussi la
relation adulte enfant pour ce
rendez-vous direction la médiathèque du
canal à montigny-le-bretonneux samedi 13
avril à 14 heures le français signé se
décline aussi en racontines cette fois
ça se passe le samedi 20 avril à
maurepas et à elancourt pour les plus
timides aussi pourquoi ne pas vous
laisser tenter par les spectacles où il
y aura des histoires d'acrobates de
clones de souris et de cochons mais des
rendez vous à vivre en famille pour ne
rien rater on fonce tout de suite sur le
site kiosque point est-ce qu y point fr
mélanie on vous retrouve dans un instant
dans un set 8 culture un peu spécial
sort ce soir on fête les 50 ans
d'ouverture au public du château de
breteuil et pour l'occasion le marquis
en gris françois de breteil nous a
ouvert les portes de son domaine
nous venons ainsi sur l'histoire de ses
50 ans mais nous allons aussi découvrir
quelques noms célèbres de la famille et
c'est ce qui fait sa popularité
aujourd'hui les contes de perrault et
ses jardins à 7,8 cultures spéciales à
retrouver bien sûr à la fin de ce
journal après ce journal merci mélanie